[Music]
horror and devastation
this was a maternity hospital
terror for babies even before they've
been born
they rushed to take her away
no safety here
ukraine's president said a russian air
strike caused this carnage and children
are under the wreckage
just look at the size of the crater
britain's prime minister called the
attack depraved and said russia's
vladimir putin will be held to account
for his crimes
for mario paul in southern ukraine it's
already a city in ruins after days of
bombardments
perhaps trying to soften its image
russia released what it said was aid
being delivered to another bombarded
city kharkiv in eastern ukraine
the kremlin also claimed without
evidence its military operation had
uncovered a ukrainian biological weapons
program
but information or disinformation is as
much of a weapon in this war as tanks
and troops and ukraine strongly denied
the allegation
far away from the front line the other
unmistakable sound of war
three ukrainian soldiers killed on
different days
remembered together
[Music]
comrades broken
by a war they're still fighting